you know the drill now uh I'm about to
introduce the next uh keynote speaker JD
Lang with a
poem introducing JD sorry JD long try
and get your name right introducing JD
long a legend in the field open source
wizard his knowledge unsealed since 2002
he pondered with might open source tools
can they take flight look at risk
management he knows it well 13 years
deep with stories to tell
with iron python python he crafts his
art Jupiter Labs our studio all play
their part in Richmond Virginia he makes
his home with wife and daughter they
brightly roam a recovering lawyer a
philosopher teen in this vibrant family
dreams a
[Laughter]
scen oh thank you all thank you very
much um you know what's funny I didn't
realize Hedley was doing the poems uh
before everyone
and this is like I'm an artist who's
been put out of business by Chad GPT
because in
2000 I don't know uh 13 years ago or
something um I spoke at the RN Finance
conference here in Chicago I did a
lightning talk because the there was
that's run out of out of here in Chicago
and my gag was I did it in Susan rhyme
and it was hilarious right because
nobody comes to a freaking Finance
conference and gives like a whole
lightning talk in sus and Ryme and now
anyone can do it and they hardly have to
work at
all so frustrating well I just want to
say hi to y'all I love being here it's
exciting to be back in Chicago I helped
start the Chicago R User Group many
years ago and it started as like we had
some some guys they were all guys at the
time it was the our in finance guys like
and myself and we were going to Jake's
tap and like talking about our right and
Jake's tap is closed now moment of
silence for Jake's tap um or was it
Jack's is Jack's tap I think anyway I
don't know uh fantastically good times
and we decided like we should just
invite other people right we're we're
having good conversation and what we'll
do is we'll do what we would like to
participate in but we'll include other
people and it's so lovely to see that
the Chicago our user group is still you
know alive and well and kind of
following that uh that ethos of you know
share the things you're doing and
include other people and that's really
kind of an our community ethos and also
you know an our studio Posite ethos and
it's makes for a fantastic community so
speaking of that like four years ago I
showed up at the art studio conference
at the time and gave a presentation and
um I wore you know a shirt with this
pattern on it because I try to explain
to people what I do for a
living and and this was the best way to
explain it because I'm an agricultural
Economist who works for a global
reinsurance company so it's easier just
to say spreadsheets and um and
Mike Smith saw this shirt and uh liked
it and I promised him one and then Co
happened and life happened and Mike
Smith come get your shirt this is for
you
Mike so we'll just uh we'll just lay
this right
here and um Mike Smith can come come
make his way down here and grab this and
if the size is wrong Mike we'll get you
one in the in the right size so I need
to I do work for a financial services
firm so I work for inance free and I am
not my employer nor am I representing
them um I'm not discussing reinsurance
here and all the ideas here are mine
unless otherwise stated uh this isn't
business this is pleasure and um a
little funny story I was trying to think
like how long I have known Hadley and
and JJ and I knew them separately before
they were working together and I
stumbled on this back in 2010 for Hadley
Wickham's birthday so 13 almost 13 years
ago last week I sent Hadley a cop copy
of generalized additive models and
introduction with r which had been on
his wish list in Amazon because he was a
poor starving faculty at Rice University
and he was maintaining open source
software and not only that he was
answering my stupid questions on stack
Overflow and I wrote in the gift note
thanks for helping me kick ass with
plier now that's the precursor to Deer
plier and R I appreciate the tools and
the help you've given me on stack
Overflow and this is the kind of
community we have right and I just think
it's hilarious Hadley had no
recollection of this I asked him about
this a couple days ago no memory of this
whatsoever but that doesn't uh keep me
from this being my financial disclosure
of my relationship ship with with
Hadley and if anybody is wondering how
you become a keynote speaker posit the
price is
$68.7 and 13 years
so well I enjoyed so I I had no idea
when I started forming this presentation
uh that Jeremy was going to be one of
the one of the keynote speakers um but I
really enjoyed listening to uh JJ and
Jeremy do this thing they called a two
AMA which I didn't know what that's
called I've been calling it having a
conversation and I'm just not really
cool right so I learned that this is
called a two-way AMA and they recorded
their two-way AMA and it's on YouTube
and it's really fantastic and I was
listening to this as I was driving from
my parents house to Nashville Tennessee
and um if my family hadn't been with me
I would have pulled over to the side of
the road cuz I was listening to just the
audio on my on my iPhone and I would
have pulled over to the side of the road
made notes so I ended up like listening
to it and going back and listening to it
again and one of the things that jumped
out is um they made the comment of if
you think about how you help both new
users ramp into things and make
experienced users productive you provide
these abstractions and there's a dial of
how leaky you want the abstraction to be
now A bunch of us who've been around
software maybe worked in software
engineering but definitely talked about
to software engineers know this idea of
abstractions and leaky abstractions in
this community a bunch of us come
through like clinical Sciences or we
come through other fields that aren't
computation first and I was thinking
like this term is really powerful both
abstractions and the idea of an
abstraction leaking these are really
important Concepts that I think we
should more widely ingest so when when
Headley contacted me and said hey you
want a keynote I'm like yeah like uh
what's what's themes or whatever and
he's Bic like I don't know you use
Python NR maybe like some you know I
don't know do do whatever you're
thinking about right well it just
happened I was thinking about this and
this has been one of the things I've
been thinking about with my team and the
people I work with is how do we talk
explicitly about abstractions leaky
abstractions and like how we deal with
those leaks so let's talk a little bit
about abstractions and leaky
abstractions so first thing I did was go
back I I thought I knew where this was
where this came from and I confirmed
that while the term leaky abstraction
was around in the Zeitgeist it really
didn't get Traction in the Tech
Community until Joel spolski wrote this
blog post over 20 years ago and he calls
it the law of leaky abstractions and the
law is all non-trivial abstractions to
some degree are leaky and what he means
by that is an abstraction failure
sometimes a little sometimes a lot
there's leakage things go wrong it
happens all over the place you have when
you have abstractions right so it means
that you have this thing you're relating
to it's abstracted away so you have an
interface an API a calling to a function
and you interface with it in a way and
it doesn't do what you expect that's a
leak so the question becomes what do you
do so you've got if you if you want to
be a master of any abstraction now not
just a user but a master of the
abstraction you have to understand
what's under the abstraction now then
you can that's the only you can di truly
debug or truly understand an abstraction
is to understand at least one layer
Beyond and I did a lot of research
trying to figure out who originally said
this concept of you've got to want
understand one abstraction below in
order to be proficient in debug one
abstraction and everything I found was
sort of like everybody just knows that
like nobody attributes that thought to
anyone it's just in the Zeitgeist that
that is reality so I guess it's like an
axiom so when we think about abstraction
I want to expand what I mean cuz many of
you probably thinking something like
this and I just like Googled Computing
abstraction right where we have at the
high level you have like a high level
language or an application and then it
goes through an assembly language
program and the assembler turns it into
machine code and then it like actually
then there's a bunch of Hardware
abstractions and then an actual
calculation gets done inside the
hardware of the machine that's how we
often think about abstractions I want to
expand that for the purpose of this
conversation because there's also
organizational abstractions so if you
think of an abstraction as we' we've got
some set of directives we're passing
down and we kind of don't care
specifically how things get done in the
next layer we just want the next layer
to do something well that's not unlike
organizational structures like I come
from Corporate America right so I think
but this generally con concept applies
to your nonprofit or you know your
software company or even your Civic
organization at some level we have a
board of directors or some committee and
they pass down you know directives and
priorities to the executive management
the executive management makes a bunch
of choices and then passes things down
to department heads who pass it to team
leads who pass it to team contributors
and if we continue to think about this
they then pass those on to computers in
some way right like they pass in because
they use applications or they use high
level coding languages or something and
then all that other stuff from the slide
before happens underneath this its
abstractions all the way down right
there's the title of my talk so why
though like why do we need these
abstractions all the way down wouldn't
it be easier if we just had like you
know I grew up on a farm and the great
thing about farming is you have to do
everything because you don't have staff
the worst thing about farming is you
have to do everything because you don't
have staff right so you become a master
of every level of abstraction until you
get in over your head and you have to
have you know John Deere repair some
piece of Machinery or something right
but you you become all the way up and
down to levels of abstraction you become
at least proficient it's been hard for
me to get used to organizations that
didn't expect me to run up and down the
stack right because I want to run up and
down all the abstractions well the
reason we can't always do that was
really articulated back in the 50s by
Herbert Simon he's an economist I'm an
economist so I got to get Economist in
here um he had this article in 1957
called administrative Behavior a study
of decision-making processes in
administrative organizations and he
coined the phrase bounded
rationality which I tldr as head trunk
only hold so much
junk which Gary Lawson captured in this
cartoon where it says Mr Osborne may I
be excused my brain is full we can only
handle so many levels of abstraction and
so many pieces of the stack before our
brain overflows and we can't make sense
of all the pieces and so we build these
interfaces and even if we are the person
traversing the levels of abstraction we
would like to interface with different
pieces of them and not think about what
happens below them even if we wrote
what's below them because it means when
we're problem solving here we don't have
to think about how the read write is
happening on the database that just
magically happens behind an abstract
interface and we don't have to think
about it and it allows us to work at the
problem solving level that's appropriate
for what we're trying to
accomplish that seems to make a lot of
sense right intuitively so let's talk a
little bit about what abstractions are
for and what they are are not for so one
thing I want to point out that they're
not for is they're not for gatekeeping
and I see this being done a lot right
you're not a real data scientist unless
you you know pie torch or deep learning
or whatever those are all different
abstractions different tools that are
used in certain places to solve certain
problems those may not be your
problems then you don't need to know
that abstraction you don't need to be
master of that abstraction you don't
need to be one layer below and I watch a
lot of early Learners run around
learning abstractions learning tools
because they feel like if they don't
know this tool they're not a real
whatever it is they think they want to
be that's really toxic because you'll
wear yourself out
because this guy has already said you
can't fit it all in your head in a
really useful way so don't let the
learning of abstractions be like oh once
I accumulate a big enough toolbox of
these abstractions then I'm a real
whatever that's just gatekeeping and
like cut that out you don't even have to
know all the abstractions you use
deeply you need but you do need to know
your limits so know which abstractions
you really understand recognize when
you're up against an abstraction that
you don't Gro so you don't understand
the abstraction it's a break point
you're like I don't really understand
what's going on Bey Beyond here at that
point you have a choice you can either
learn that abstraction learn what's
really going on Beyond it so that you
can deeply understand it or you can
partner with someone who's an expert
there partnership and pairing with
someone else and working with someone
else is always an option it may be
harder in some organizations than others
especially if you're like the only
person on the data science team um you
may feel some pressure to learn those
abstraction and that may be the right
choice but if you're in a large
organization and someone else in the
organization is a master of that
abstraction you may not need to become
the expert on database indexing right
contact Cara she seems to know a lot
about
it and we have to choose make that
choice now what I see happen a lot is
people blame an abstraction for problems
when they bump up against it and often
the problem is they don't understand
what the abstraction is doing now that
may be a leaky abstraction but still
it's like okay my dashboard doesn't
refresh fast enough my database has a
problem I had literally this one within
the last year and I worked with the uh
powerbi developer and we discovered that
when using direct query in powerbi which
is how you access any database that
isn't the one that's built into
powerbi it issues all the queries in
series and will not issue them in
parallel so the dashboard had you know
13 queries that all took 3 seconds they
could have been run in parallel and the
whole thing refreshed in 3 seconds
instead it took 13 times three because
it was running in serial and the the
analyst had thought oh this database is
crap and I'm like actually Microsoft is
shunting you into buying more cloud
storage so you can shove your data into
their platform instead of letting you
use your own perfectly good database
because they force your connection to
issue queries and cial and I'm like
that's broken right that's not a leaky
abstraction by accident that's a leaky
abstraction by sales right and that
should make anybody that runs into that
one angry and it made me angry and I'm
like we got to get other tools this is
ridiculous like we're being manipulated
we're being played and my analyst didn't
know it right because he didn't really
understand that abstraction he didn't
realize how to go into the database get
the logs and see that they were
happening in
serial but he does now right but that's
an example of don't blame the
abstraction understand the abstraction
understand what's going on and then
decide what you want to do with that
information so I would if I did anything
where I dabble with like Computer
sciency Concepts and I don't quote um
Edgar disra here I would probably be
remiss so he has this kind of great um
quote that says programming when
stripped of all its circumstantial
irrelevancies boils down to no more and
no less than very effective thinking so
as to avoid unmastered complexity to
very vigorous separations of your many
different concerns right and the tldr is
constrained complexity and separate
concerns that's what we're trying to do
with abstractions and that's what you
should be doing when you're writing
functions inside your in-house libraries
your first priority should be how do we
make it less complex how do we separate
conern concerns and that's that even if
you understand and you built the pieces
that are under certain abstractions if
you can separate those from your
thinking while you think about this
piece of the problem you've got less of
a sand castle in your head to build the
tools and do the analysis you want to
deal with because you've got a lot of
the complexity pushed away and you know
that if you have a certain problem which
piece of complexity you then need to go
look at it's not all commingle together
so that's a really good concept and that
was you know he wrote that down in 197
and I'm not sure we've done a really
good job embracing that I know I
haven't so let's do a fun example about
AB thinking about abstractions uh
anybody in here an electrical
engineer oh more than I expected I'm
going to ask you guys like not to yell
at me like just just stick with me just
stick with me it's a thought exercise
don't rush the stage here
um electricity is a fundamental
abstraction for computing obviously
right we know this is all powered by
electricity we know like we've got
gigabit switches in our office so that's
a billion bits of information a second
there's a bunch of wires and we don't
really know how that works but it's got
to be at least going like millions of
ups and downs of voltage a second right
inside your gigabit switch that little
light blinks fast right it feels like
something like that and so like how fast
do the electrons flow in our wire
so just think about this for a minute
don't yell an answer how fast do they go
and I'm like well okay well we're
flipping the little bits up and down you
know a million times a second or more
maybe a billion in The Wire some big
number um that's really fast that's a
lot of that's got to be moving fast to
turn it on and turn it off that fast it
feels really fast you know I don't open
the refrigerator door and it's dusk it's
always you know light straight on I when
I was in Middle School they showed me
illustrations that look like this and I
think the red balls are the electrons
right so the battery forces the
electrons through so those things must
be going really fast you know and then
the next year the teacher did this
diagram and likened electric current
flow to like water flow and you know
resistor was like a restriction on the
pipe and we and we got that and that was
was really helpful so this all kind of
points me to this stuff's going like
really fast we're probably going near
speed of light but it can't be the speed
of light it's you know there's some some
uh resistance from The Wire and that's
why wires get hot so but it can't be too
much because they get really hot all the
time and they don't so I don't know
we're probably pushing the speed of
light inside these water I sorry inside
these wires right yeah no it's 8
centimeters an hour at one
watt what right okay who was surprised
by that number like it kind of defied
your intuition the ones with your hands
down you guys are like smarter than me
uh and I'm glad you're here cuz I want
to know smart people um the problem is
we conflate electromagnetic fields with
electron movement so the electromagnetic
field moves really fast the actual
electrons move quite slow so in an AC
wire when you're uh you know drying your
hair it's something like
this that's the speed of the actual
electrons moving Through the Wire which
kind of blows a lot of people's
intuition when they learned with these
metaphors like I showed you on the
previous slide um if anybody finds this
interesting and would like to go read
more by the way uh if you want to take
pictures in my slides or anything that's
great knock yourself out at the end
there's a QR code that'll take you to
GitHub repo that has the whole slide in
there so don't feel like you got to
capture the links or anything um but
this is a link to a YouTube video that
explains this this whole thing and and
it's really interesting I found but why
do many of us not know this right
because we use Electronics in Mass every
day to solve all our
problems well the reason we don't know
this is it doesn't matter like and not
that it doesn't matter that we don't
know it like it doesn't matter like it
it doesn't change anything like there's
absolutely nothing you ever know where
the movement of the electron matters
right that abstraction never leaks we
never are diagnosing a problem and we're
like I finally get the the answer it's
because I thought the electrons were
moving fast and they're actually moving
slow like that's never the problem we
have because this abstraction just
doesn't leak now there's a whole genre
of YouTube videos and clickbait that are
basically like this right like they they
surprise you with some piece of
information you didn't know about
something that you interact with all the
time and sometimes they're like
absolutely full of crap because we like
this because it's surprising and we get
a little dopamine drop when we're
surprised by you know
information and some point though it
doesn't matter
so you know to to understand abstraction
we build these mental models we make
metaphors like my water flow or my
electrons being elevated and moved and
dropping often they're wrong metaphors
and sometimes that doesn't matter
because they allow us to understand the
thing well enough to use it so I do my
own like home electrical wiring I'm
rewiring uh I redid my Jeep wiring I'm
doing a trailer now I use computers I've
got a desk with uh you know power supply
on it for testing arduinos and
controlling uh you know actuators with
um with arduinos and raspberry pies and
it never matters that I completely
misunderstood how electrons flow through
a wire so my metaphor was good enough
even though it was technically
wrong well what if our mental model is
wrong and it does matter CU you know
it's not a universal case that it
doesn't matter so buckle up let's talk
about floating Point math this is my
favorite leaky abstraction and by the
way I'm only going to have two slides
with code and they're both python
because we got a big Community we're
very open ENT
you know if you took uh you know grade
school math everyone in here did at some
point the teacher and if they were very
creative uh they did a pretty slide like
this one to explain the associative
property of addition where it doesn't
matter how you group the things you're
adding you get the same answer and we're
taught this very young and this is how
addition and multiplication work and you
know I think we all saw something like
this stole this slide literally from a
you know a middle school review
online but we come into Python and we go
okay well we got these numbers they're
real numbers they're on the number line
right we're going to take 1.11 add 2.22
and then we're going to add
3.33 and we're going to group them a
little different and they are not the
same and the reason they are not the
same is floating Point addition and
multiplication are not
associative and the reason why is
Illustrated when I format the print on
these to sew 17 decimal points because
way out there in it doesn't matter
practically to you land most of the time
out there in the 14 15 16 17 to decimal
point you can see these numbers are just
a little bit different and that's
because floating Point numbers are an
abst abration they're not literal point
on the number line like we were taught
in grade school about numbers there's
something different to make it work in
computers and this is why daddy
[Applause]
drinks and it's things like this that
will drive you insane because we even
though most of us understand this about
floating Point math I'll tell you a very
quick story about where I spent two days
with an engineer last week then it was a
floating Point math problem but it
didn't come at us as just value a equals
value B what we were doing was we were
doing a bunch of math and then we rank
it and after we rank it we then say Okay
I want the row number and we use a
second um sorting number to say you know
basically if there's ties use this other
value you know use this deterministic
number over here to break ties because
we want all of our systems to be
deterministic meaning that there's no
random number generation here so every
time I run it I want it to barf out
exactly the same answer no swapping
values around right this is huge it
ingests like five billion records and
and barfs out 11 million after a bunch
of aggregations
and we were finding we weren't getting
deterministic answers now out of 11
million maybe we would have 30 that
would change every run and we were like
that's not cool what's going on and as
we dug into it what we found is some of
the condition that should have been a
tie was
like this situation where I was showing
you where it's conceptually the same
number but they were flipping because
and the reason it was happening is we
were on spark Spark's a distributed
system you don't control which executors
or how the groupings are done because
it's map reduce so every time we ran it
and maybe we ran it with a different
cluster size maybe one machine would got
the data first little things change and
so when we aggregated these up we' get
slightly different floating Point
rounding because of the way they were
grouped and it became material because
of that sort order problem we thought we
were handling ties with numbers but we
weren't so I mean that was easy to solve
right we just round those to some
smaller number you know or we cast them
into something with less Precision so we
get rid of that noise out in floating
Point Land you know but we spent two of
our time for like well I think there's
more people than that involved for like
four days trying to figure out why the
hell these numbers keep changing right
why is there a ghost in my machine well
if you're interested in this this isn't
a presentation about floating Point
numbers even though it may feel like it
right now I recommend reading Julia
Evans you may know where is bour um
article about floating Point numbers in
she does a number of fantastic Computer
sciency Zen complaining complaining uh
explaining these Concepts using uh using
cartoons and they're fantastic and you
know she points out that doing numerical
computations on a computer inherently
involves some approximation and rounding
right that's one thing we should all
come in this with knowing all
right enough of floating Point math I'm
an agricultural Economist let's talk
about
silos so
uh Cara mentioned silos in organizations
right and so let's think about using our
mindset of an abstraction let's think
about silos for a
minute what are if if organizations are
abstractions what's the abstraction
equivalent of a organizational Silo and
I would say that's a over restrictive
abstraction and it's an abstraction that
when it leaks you can't figure out why
so let's think what that what what org
abstraction leakage looked like so where
did this number in the DB in the
database where did it come from if your
organization is highly siloed you may
not be able to answer that question if
your team didn't calculate it that's an
overly
rigid um abstraction who do I talk to
about solving this problem whatever that
problem may be if you can't answer that
you've got a siloed organization right
it's overly rigid abstraction and how
was this decision made right
non-computational right it may just be
like you know we're making decisions
about people we're making decisions
about uh a number of different things
how were they made
well the general evidence of leaking
abstraction what are those my these are
like I went looking for surely people
have articulated this and I couldn't
really find any other authors or
academic authors who would really
outline this I am sure it's out there
and I am Reinventing the wheel but the
thing I'm always looking for is unexpect
unexpected
Behavior uninterpretable responses or
logical errors where I where I there's
no explanation and whether that's my
computer or my organization those are
all signs of slippage or leakage in the
abstractions so I think of a bunch of
this is really in an organization it's
communication problem and communication
is like beer it's the communication is
the source of and solution to all our
problems so you know if you run into
where did this number in the DB comes
from there's ways that we can improve
communication our organization to answer
this right we can have the code for the
ETL or whatever in Version Control so
get GitHub whatever Version Control you
use and
available to the people in the
organization who consume the values
right and that's really important
because a lot of organizations do not
share read only is fine but they don't
share the ETL process for how they do
things with the people who are consuming
those things that's Insanity right like
we can read code many of us who are
doing things with the data show us how
it was calculated because it may answer
a whole bunch of questions we have about
what we're trying to do and you know a
Wiki page describing the process of
there's a complicated um decision that's
made in How We Do grouping we always
omit this we always include that that
sort of stuff put that junk in a Wiki or
documentation that's easily accessible
so similarly like the question how do I
talk about solving this well if
everything in the organization has clear
ownership that one gets resolved really
fast because you talk to the owner of
that process or that system and we often
let ownership slip and things get
orphaned and then they just leak like
all over the floor because there's no
person whose job it is to explain why
it's leaking or help stop the leak or
help you understand what the system is
doing uh and then things like how was
this decision made well that's better
transparency leadership communication
somebody didn't communicate how a
decision was made or what the process
was and a bunch of times those are
easily solved by communication and
probably for big decisions they need to
be communicated multiple times in
multiple ways on multiple methods so a
video a All Hands call an email um you
know one of the struggles I have is
people tend to act like email is a
reasonable way to access me when they
put me on
BCC I don't read if I'm on BCC the
volume of email I get I can barely read
the stuff that's gotten my name spelled
right and everything else goes into a
folder named like BCC read
later
later and I every once in a while I miss
an an inter important internal corporate
communication because I wasn't paying
attention to that but my email volume is
much more manageable so don't
communicate very important things to
your organization with them all on
BCC um so sometimes we need multiple
methods to communicate to make sure the
message isn't dropped all right with
that said that's a little bit about
organizational abstraction leakage and
how we might address that I I want to do
a little history and it wouldn't be a
data science conference with an old man
at the front if we didn't put up Drew
Conway's Vin diagram from
2010 now funny story uh I knew Drew when
he was PhD student at NYU and I saw him
like draw this out on a napkin and it
like completely blew my brain when 5
years later like the Actuarial magazines
on my Actuarial Department desk at work
like had this diagram on the cover I'm
like this is so weird so sometimes I
feel like I'm the farest Gump of data
science it's like I was sitting at the
bar when Drew Conway wrote this on a
napkin right I didn't actually do
anything but you know I saw it go down
um so what's interesting about this and
the reason I want to bring it up is the
thing that was so revolutionary about
this in 2010 inside of organizations is
these are three different abstractions
and they one person was not only wasn't
expected to do this one person in many
or ganizations was not allowed to do
this I can remember many times in the
early 2000 being told I couldn't have
coding tools on my machine at work
because I was not a software developer
and I'm like I don't think you
understand what we're doing and what
these tools are right and it's like Oh
no you're in the business you get you
know
Excel and I'm like I can write code in
VBA you're not going to like it why do I
have to use the shitty code when I could
write good code and you're just shunting
me into that because it's the
abstraction you're comfortable with it's
not the abstraction I'm comfortable with
and what happen since then so in in only
you know 13 years is it's now totally
acceptable almost everywhere except a
few backwards government organizations
for people who are doing like data
sciency work in the business doing
analytical work to have first class
programming tools you know on their
machine and they have rights and
permissions to use those and often
install packages and even if that's from
a curated internal repo but we can do
these things that 13 years ago we were
literally told we were not allowed to do
that's a fundamental change and I will
assert that the single biggest business
value derived from the data science
movement in the last 13 years is making
it legitimate to code outside of it
software development roles now that's a
pretty big assertion right a lot of
value has come out of data science but
this is the inside of these big
calcified organizations seeing all Drew
Conway's diagram inside of magazines and
Executives say well how do we get that
and I look over the shoulder and say
stop being stupid about the rules of
what we put on our desktop or give us
access to you know coding tools through
a Jupiter lab or through our studio
that's centrally hosted you know that
opened up for these tools to permeate
across
organizations and so these data science
roles break previous organizational
abstractions is is my point there right
I'll make a second assertion and it's
tied into what we looked at talked about
earlier abstractions will leak spolsky
told us that therefore abstractions must
be permeable to allow
debugging so that's my thing of put your
ETL code where everyone can read it who
might be using the results of it that's
allowing us to at least peek through the
abstraction and see what we're getting
this holds for both organizations and
computers so inside of organizations we
need to understand when those
organizational structures leak how do we
deal how do we Peak behind the layer of
abstraction now for me I've been in an
organization an ins the same
organization for an insane number of
years I've been at the same employer for
14 years had the same boss for 12 years
like my solution is easy because of that
I start calling people right and hey
what's going on with whatever you know
or sending them a text message you know
but my analyst don't know who to don't
know who to contact so I've got to be
that to them so I've got to go to them
and ask questions of hey do you guys
understand what's happening do you
understand why uh and then we we talk
and I go okay some of you may have had
questions or thoughts that you weren't
comfortable bringing in the group feel
free to hit me up oneon-one like what
I'm trying to do is is is these things
may be leaking for you it's okay come to
me talk about it we'll we'll deal with
the leaks and I'll help you understand
what's going on and this is Germain
because we're right in the middle of
acquiring another company and there's
lots of questions right and some of it I
have answers to and some of it I don't
but that's how we handle it so there's
AB leaky abstractions all the way up and
down your organization and all the way
up and down our Tech Stacks all right my
assertion three no single abstraction is
right for everyone I think we're going
to need more abstractions now we have
found in in our organization this is the
part where I'm going to share some
things that's not just my
thoughts my um colleague Shan Moore and
Peter ilston uh another one of my
colleagues came up with what we call the
80164 and it really started as the 8020
Rule and then we realized we needed to
divide the 20 you know into two buckets
so we applied the 8020 rule to the 20
and we got 80164 because Math is fun and
we like we like non- Galan distributions
right given given our world so the way
we think about everything we do is 80 %
of our users in our organization are
normal business users now I'm going to
present all this like from a for-profit
corporate organization they should
project into your world and don't even
though I've got like numbers up here
like don't be obsessed with what that
means right this conceptual the vast
majority of your folks are normal
business users they want to use
applications dashboards basic Excel
that's their tool stack those are their
abstractions and then 16% or so
are super users right super users are
going to want to do like SQL against the
underlying data that's collected by your
tools they may want to do like a custom
dashboard they're going to do some
Advanced Excel like pivot tables and
really processing the data a bit more
and then 4% are Guru users your Guru
users are like oh I want to do that but
I want to do it 10,000 times so can I
hit the API and just do that directly
pull a result back make a change put it
in run your thing pull it back you know
that's a very different use case or
maybe they want a library a python
Library an R library that interacts with
your corporate tooling very different
abstractions needed by these three
different groups and they're cumulative
right so the way I think about it is
your super users they will use the you
know dashboards and the basic Excel but
they also want these other things your
Guru users are of course still using SQL
right and they're still using your
applications they're using everything um
this has been um incredibly helpful for
us because what I had observed in our
organization and in others is a tendency
to like scratch the 80% itch and then
kind of
stop and make it hard to get the
underlying data and we had had at times
in our culture where that wasn't the
case and then as we started specializing
teams some of this 16 and four was
getting dropped sometimes so so you know
we've changed kind of the definition of
done on the things we build saying we've
got to make sure people from all three
of these groups agree that they have
what they need now it doesn't mean that
everything we do has an API right that's
not the principle the principle is what
the people in that group need they have
access to and I try to be real careful
like don't hear me saying you know build
apis everywhere because then all of
these no you're working backwards work
from the principle not from the
implementation we Implement what we need
to address the principle how do you know
like what your Guru users need well just
make them an API no you're going to go
ask them right back to communication and
they may say oh if I just have access to
the output data in SQL that's more than
enough for me great don't build anything
specifically for them uh this is where
like I I really like the current
movement for data products because data
products are used data product meaning
like it's defined it's got a uh data
dictionary it's not like tied in
necessarily to the whole corporate
database but it's a a standalone data
product all the fields are defined and
in our shop we have a link to a Wiki
page and a link to the source code that
builds that data product available for
everyone I love that like even though
when I first heard data product I
thought it was like more marketing BS
and I just wasn't excited about it when
I saw what I got from it I'm like oh
yeah data product I want that because a
whole bunch of my 16 and fours needs are
addressed by having a good data product
right because it's a good abstraction
that we can Peak behind because of the
documentation and the links to the
source code so it's fantastic so like
the point there is multiple abstractions
is a high empathy move right I'm here
with my practice radical empathy shirt
on that's high empathy for who's
actually using it building apis blind ly
because Gartner says that's a good idea
is not a high empathy move right that's
just parting you know what someone you
believe to be a thought leader don't do
that think right think about what people
actually need and build what they
actually need and more importantly don't
build stuff they don't need and that's
hugely empathetic so my big idea recap
is abstractions start way up with
leaders and glow all the way down to the
hardware it's abstra all the way up and
down to debug an abstraction you have to
see what's below it we're building
mental models of complex systems and
that's why we need abstractions because
we can't hold it all in our head at once
you can't master all
abstractions decide if you're going to
learn or if you're going to partner but
don't decide to blame the abstraction
you don't know Ure an abstraction is for
everyone my metric for that is the 8164
but don't be dumb about it and more
importantly just like Hadley helped me
years ago on stack Overflow help
everyone kick ass because almost nobody
really wants to know how to code or do
these things we just want to solve some
problem as Cara said or as I say we just
want to kick ass right so here's the uh
QR code that'll go to these slides uh
there's my LinkedIn and my Mastadon if
you guys want to hit me up there I'm
happy to happy to talk to y'all and we
got a few minutes so let's get Headley
and do some
Q&A
thank you thank you thank
you so I had one question to to warm you
up so obviously I'm like a huge fan of
abstractions a lot of my work is just
creating abstractions but one of the
other things I enjoy is like in my
personal life like discovering kind of
abstractions that make something outside
of work interesting like do you have any
examples of that in your life where
youve disc discover an abstraction that
you really love oh yeah and it's so
nerdy let me think how to how to
summarize this so I like old machines
and I got an old jeep that has no moving
part on it that's an original Jeep so
it's got a a Chevy small block in it and
it's had the carburetor replaced with a
throttle body fuel injection so that's a
fuel delivery device that sits where the
carburator could go but it's got little
jets in a computer right like a modern
vehicle but it's squirting into like a
19 69 small black Chevy engine and it is
so fantastic to read the discussion
boards uh and the people
debugging uh throttle body uh electronic
fuel injection because they bring their
carburetor metaphors in and they don't
work and they are just mad in hell at
this thing being broken that it doesn't
work right and it's because they don't
understand the abstraction and I think
about this a lot like I find debugging
the issues with my electronic fuel
injection pretty straightforward because
it's not really a complicated system
it's got like two sensors you just sense
the air flow and you sense the oxygen at
the tailpipe and it's a pretty
straightforward control system but if
you don't understand some of the nuances
you just bang your head against
debugging it and so it's very much like
this to
me can you suggest things to watch for
that kind of signal that maybe we've
Fallen too far down like some particular
abstraction hole and we need to like
pull back up or think of another look at
another abstraction yeah that that's a
good that's a good point and I wish I
had these guidelines and I might if I
had them I might anonymously send them
to the spark development team
uh by the way I I use spark a lot and
this this talk was largely inspired by
banging my head against a bunch of
things in spark uh it is the leakiest
abstraction of any useful piece of
software I've dealt with soft W that
leaked more but it wasn't useful spark
is incredibly useful and it leaks like C
right like the abstractions are so leaky
um how to know
like I think we should always like this
is some real step cvy seven steps of
highly effective people advice but we
need to keep the end in mind like what
problem are we solving the goal isn't
more abstractions the goal is
compartmentalization of concerns and the
problem and if we're spending all of our
time redefining new abstractions because
we have an abstraction fetish that may
not be healthy but it is a little bit
gray sometimes to know the right level
abstractions or if you build an
abstraction that's too compartmentalized
I mean I think one of the examples
that's floating around right now in the
Zeitgeist online is the discussion of
microservices and how lots of companies
the development teams have looked at
what Amazon and Google uh do and are
like oh yeah everything has to be a
microservice what is a microservice but
a very specific abstraction right so so
they build thousands of these and like
they're not Amazon they're not Google
they don't need that that could have
been solved you know with a query could
have replaced five
microservices um that's an example of
kind of losing sight of the problem and
following the advice blindly of
microservices are good or apis are good
so keep the in problem in mind of what
problem we're actually going to try to
solve how's it going to be used you know
and one of the things I do is I love
user personas and people in marketing
use user personas and they're often
quite vague like they'll they'll be an
imaginary person I've used this in other
talks but my favorite is is an Taylor
the woman's Clothier there is no person
named an Taylor Taylor but you couldn't
tell that inside of the design meetings
at an Taylor because she is a real
person like she has a dog dog has a name
she has an address she has a job you
know she has like they completely
describe her and that's who they make
clothes for well marketing does that
because they don't know their customers
so they create usually a few different
personas that they are targeting and I
watch software development teams like
inside of our organization we've got
like under a thousand people and I have
sat in meetings where they debated what
does this user Persona want from this
and I'm like that's Robin call Robin and
ask him like wh why are we why are we
messing around with like dreaming up our
our put a name on every user Persona if
your organization's small and then ask
that person is this solving your problem
and they may go yes or they may go no
actually making it more complicated
right so one way to stay out of that is
make sure what problem you're solving
who you're solving it for and ask
them so we got a couple of questions
about the
8164 RO yes so the first one is like how
can we kind of like keep our empathy for
that 80% and protect them and how do we
avoid them from just being kind of seen
as these like low skilled low status
people like the Disposable po post dos
of of
Academia um yeah it depends on your
organization so like in my
shop I have empathy for them but I don't
build most of my tools most of the time
are not for them I'm I'm they're using
tools that put things into systems and
I'm accessing it in the system so you
know I want to make sure that they're
taken care of by our software
development team but but they're not
mine to take care of they need sets of
tooling so in some ways like they may
not be your responsibility in depending
on how you ganizations laid out that's
somebody else's responsibility if
they're your responsibility well you got
to figure out how to have empathy for
them and make the tooling they need but
don't try to make them a 16 or a four
don't try to make them a power user or
Guru if they don't have any interest in
being but if you get some of those
regular users and we see this we'll get
users that are like I can I is it
possible that I could write a query to
get this data out and we're like yeah
let's let's talk about it I can show you
how to do that right and so we'll move
people but it is isn't a career
prerequisite that people be moving from
the 80 to the 6 it's not a career path
map right it's an organizational
structure and so if you're responsible
for them figure out how to love them if
you're not responsible for them eat
lunch with them so you understand their
world but don't uh you know don't like I
don't sit around worrying are they
getting their needs met that's somebody
else's job yeah actually oned both of
the questions and that fantastic twofer
I like it so I had I had a question for
you about some specific kind of metap of
today and how you like think about them
I think like the data warehouse the data
Lake yes and now like the combination of
the two which is the data Lake housee
yeah oh my
God I have dropped so much profanity
mocking this marketing language around
these things let me tell
you how I think about it the the data
warehouse means to me or the way I
assume people mean and I'm afraid people
use these different L um the what it
means to me is some thought has been
given to creating fact tables and
dimensions and star or snowflake schemas
that cover multiple areas of the
business and it's usually a very big
lift to create a data warehouse um it
takes a lot of top down orchestration to
figure out the right glandularity of the
data for your fact tables and which
things are dimensions and and all of
this so it's a super highly structured
but really powerful but the problem
becomes it's really hard to get new
stuff in because it's a big change and
you will never change the granularity of
it right once that granularity the grain
of the data you can't it's not easy to
change I mean it can be done but it it
will be a big lift to do that so it's
going to be slower moving but it's super
valuable the
data um let's see data Lake was the data
Lake approach is a little more You've
Got A system that data out capture it
right like you're just cap you know it
may be logs it may be some sets of
results you're just accumulating those
in a way where they could be queried
later and then data Lakehouse is like
let's try to do a little bit of both all
at once and we're going to see I mean
often what that means is you create a
bunch of ETL processes in your data Lake
to extract things that are interesting
and drop them in a schema where people
can use them that's usually what it is
is ETL and top of your data Lake um
that's great I think calling I think it
can a lot of these are marketing terms
to try to get people to talk about it I
think I'm back to what problem are you
trying to solve right so if we
understand what problem we're going to
solve it may be fine to do one where it
maybe we need the other um and very few
people are building huge data warehouses
in my limited experience because of this
big cost low agility feature
very slow to build and they're very slow
to change and they're costly to build
and because it spreads many parts of the
organization everybody hates them
fractionally in their own special way
um and so I think that's part and also
storage has gotten so cheap right so we
can just kind of forget about Dimension
tables we just repeat our data uh
because we have um columnar databases so
that's not near as costly and storage is
cheap so we end up doing lots of you
know big flat tables stuck there that
are useful and so we just think less
about data modeling and you'll know when
you're thinking too little about data
modeling because your life starts
sucking and then you're like maybe we
should uh maybe we should have given
some thought to data modeling and you go
back and do it and we're all figuring
this out sort of emergently and
organically hope that answered it okay I
think we've got time for one last
question let's do it and I'm not sure
whether this is for you or for me but
I'm going to give it to you all right
I'll give it back uh how leaky do you
consider something like Deepa okay so I
literally told Davis at dinner two
nights ago that the thing I like about
deer is for SQL like Transformations so
kind of the normal stuff you might do
with SQL I consider deer as like an
appliance not like one of the definition
of Appliance is it just does what it's
supposed to do you don't think about it
right your dishwasher you don't think
about how it works it just works D plier
for a lot of that sort of stuff I think
it's it's it's very unley now I think if
you start trying to do more complicated
things and start trying to do you know
data frames inside of data frames or
whatever that foolishness is you let
people
do those probably leak but I don't know
because I don't do them but um it's it's
really good for a bunch of stuff and you
guys have slowly morphed it over time
like how you change the cast and melt to
the pivot longer pivot wider um that
been actually that has taken leakiness
away and taking friction away now it's
got pain points because you changed an
API uh but it's it's really helpful in
reducing leak so I consider deer not
particularly leaky what do you think
about that how would you answer that
yeah I I would say I I don't know the
the thing that I think about the most is
like DB plier DB plier leaks like a Civ
yeah well you're trying to translate
arode to sequel yeah but like yes it
leaks at some level yes it leaks like
but like amazing like it works most of
the stuff think the thing that's most
surprising to me is like most of the
stuff you're trying to do the data right
for like filtering and aggregation it's
you can do it in I you can do it in
JavaScript you can do it in SQL you can
do in Python it's all basically the same
and we can translate between that like
with pretty high Fatality and that
that's like pretty surprising it really
is kind of surprising where it leaks is
kind of akin to how SQL leaks in that
you start a accumulating lots and lots
of steps and then at some point you get
unexpected Behavior that's not unique to
DB plier that's a little bit of the
underlying SQL I have the same problem
in SQL and then you have a permeating
the membrane problem because at some
point you go fine dump the query out and
I dump the query out and you say oh god
what have I done and you know I have my
dbas tell me I can tell when you're
doing a DB query because it's got really
crazy SQL that no one would write yeah
and so when it comes time to solve some
of those problems some of them aren't
yours some of them are SQL but it's it's
can be a little tricky it's a harder
yeah that makes me think a fun talk
would be just that we could spend
probably 30 minutes just talking about
how leaky and abstraction SQL is oh we
really could right I I I was tempted to
jump into that but I was like no I want
super succinct example and floating
point was just so succinct so thank you
all very much it's been a pleasure to
hang out with you thank you
J
we go for lunch just a couple of uh
quick announcements this is kind of the
last time we're going to be all here uh
together in person so I just wanted to
start by saying thank
you first of all I really wanted to
thank all of our speakers they have been
working on their talks in in conjunction
with our training partner for like weeks
now and I think you can really see the
results of that and the the the
uniformly high quality of the talks this
year I'd also like to thank all of the
sponsors uh if you haven't stopped by
the lounge already uh make sure to do
that the many of most of them have got
booths there find out the cool stuff
they're doing you know they're here at
us at at com because we believe and they
believe that they can help you solve
your
problems I'd also like to give a big
thanks to all of my colleagues at poset
the the colleagues who are here both
here in person uh solving the many
logistical problems that have occurred
so that you never experienced them and
to the many uh employees who are also
working online as well uh in particular
I'd really like to thank thank uh
Caitlyn and Brian who run our events
team they have done just such a fabulous
job at comp this year
and finally I'd like to thank all of you
all obviously the com wouldn't happen
without your enthusiasm and uh love for
R and Python and data science and it's
been so wonderful to meet so many of you
here in
person now you're probably getting sick
of clapping and you really want to hear
uh the next thing I'm going to tell you
and that is where is comp going to be
next
year and that is posit com 2024 or in a
uh effort to embrace our python
colleagues we also going to call it from
posit import comp com
2024 uh but seriously it's going to be
in Seattle next
year
if you look closely at those dates you
might notice it is one day shorter than
usual so next year we're going to be
experimenting with just doing a single
day of workshops uh we're trying to
bring the overall cost of com down we we
decreasing the ticket prices a fair
amount and also just making the whole
thing a little bit cheaper uh by
reducing it by one day uh I also have an
apology to make to the uh the members of
The Vampire Community who are with us
this year uh we're going to have many
windows next year and there'll be a lot
of daylight as well so as always uh the
best the cheapest possible price to get
a ticket is our super fans price that's
$6.99 that's going to be on sale until
October 6th uh we'll be sending out an
email to everyone who register in the
comp in the next couple of days so you
can sign up for next year if you want so
thanks again uh please enjoy the rest of
the conference and if I don't get to see
you or meet you person
I really appreciate you being here and
great Lu good luck with data science and
and the rest of your life
[Applause]
thanks